ol son réglage bonsoir bonsoir orelsan
on vous a connu avec sa décision''
adverbe été rectum même si tu disait des
trucs intelligents torre d'ercole j'te
déteste que tu crèves lentement je veux
que tu tombes enceinte et que tu perdes
l'enfant voit la bombe sale [ __ ] le
scandale ségolène royal a voulu vous
faire déprogrammé des francofolies vous
avez été soutenu par frédéric lefebvre
est soutenu par frédéric lefebvre pour
un rappeur c'est un peu la honte quand
même or il se tait n'importe quoi mais
beaucoup d'artistes m'ont soutenu aussi
et c'est là où j'étais plus ça m'a plus
fait plaisir il a déclaré je fais ce que
je veux dans mes chansons je ne
renoncerai pas à la musique que j'ai
envie de faire mais un sur au delà de la
liberté d'expression et à la liberté de
création c'est super important alors
votre maman qui est institutrice dans la
pensée quoi elle vous a ni très bien où
passable
forcément ils écoutent pas sale [ __ ]
tous les matins mais il ya d'autres
chansons à moi qu'elle aime bien
alors justement une mère institutrice un
père directeur de collège des origines
normandes des études de management vous
êtes blanc ça fait pas mal de handicap
pour devenir rappeur
évidemment emma musicale va pas
ressembler à celle de tupac ouais mais
du coup non ça va je pense que tant que
tant qu'on fait quelque chose je sais
pas qui parle aux gens qui communiquent
des émotions ça peut être n'importe quel
style de musique ensuite vous avez
remporté deux victoires de la musique
avec votre deuxième album vous revenez
dans les bacs avec un disque intitulé
orelsan et grainge sont les casseurs
floaters si les noms des deux méchants
dans maman j'ai raté l'avion des gens
leur ressembler un peu physiquement
grâce délai plutôt grand et maigre et
moi j'étais plus petit et trapu à
l'époque mais c'est marrant parce qu on
a tourné plutôt des références à à
scarface
ouais on en parle dans l'album on dit
qu'avec le recul tony montana il est
bien à chier
ou alors maman j'ai raté pas passe bien
alors tous les deux vous êtes originaire
de caen grince vous saviez qu'aurélien
râpé mais vous ne le connaissiez pas et
un jour il a débarqué dans le magasin de
skate ou vous travaillez en 1999 il vous
a proposé de monter un groupe et là vous
êtes retrouvé dans un resto mexicain en
face du magasin de skate et vous dites
orelsan vu ce qu'il a commandé à manger
je savais qu'il avait le potentiel quand
même état dans la costume de sepa
militaire cambodgien un truc un peu déjà
il était décalée c'est la première fois
que je mange au resto sans mes parents
mais elle avait 17 ans il m'a dit viens
on va au resto gfa tu profites turquie
sans vie de ses choristes alors lequel
adam g du strict d'autruche en buvant du
jus de quelques rires ça va avec le
costume cambodgiens se prendre un steak
d'autruche et un jeu de cactus et je me
suis dit ce mec est fou gt gt déjà sous
le charme d'entrée quoi alors à part une
mixtape il aura fallu attendre 14 ans
pour que vous sortiez un truc ensemble
pendant ce temps là vous participiez à
ses albums à ses tournées en fait c'est
surtout vécu à ses crochets quand même
ouais ouais mais là c'est complètement
assumé ses on était plusieurs à vivre au
crochet d'oreilles comme leur entourage
finalement c'est ça c'est entourage mais
sans les on va s'acheter des lamborghini
la chronique alors l'album est un buddy
movie qui raconte 24 heures de deux
losers chaque morceau est une scène dans
le film de cette journée c'est très
autobiographique ans maintenant ouais
carrément pour nous en fait c'est un
album constitué ya à peu près quatre ans
quand on vivait ensemble quand il y
avait beaucoup de potes à la baraque et
quand on n'avait pas vraiment d'objectif
ckoi grange le pire moment de cette
époque là où on nous différencier les
chorales cycle est toujours c'est un mec
toujours très actif qui quittent
d'autant que caen n'a pas l'air comme ça
mais qui fait toujours plein de trucs à
la fois et moi j'ai pas mal tendance à
végéter à m'installer là dedans et ça a
été ce truc d'oisiveté qui s'est un peu
qu'un petit peu trop duré un moment je
me suis réveillé les les gens s'habiller
différemment le loupé un truc on
habitait ensemble est et des fois j'ai
des potes qui venaient à la maison et me
dit ouais il fait quoi grandgil en
vacances et aussi tous ses ballons il
est dans sa chambre et des effets mais
ça fait ça fait trois semaines qu'on
vient et touring garé devant la presse à
la garde à vue sous la porte et je ne
s'était pas de match et tu es mieux au
boulou la ouais c'est dur même si
vous êtes un duo maintenant ouais alors
qui est stone qui et charden dans le
hall
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux